(upbeat music)
- Hello, now it's time for
tonight's #HashtagWars.
(applause)
- Yes Ron Funches.
- Turkey?
- Points, perfect right there.
It was right there!
And now I'm tired.
Nikki Glaser.
- Snack Pack-istan.
- Yes, points (laughs)
Jon Daly.
- Saskatchew-Won-Ton Soup.
- Points.
Ron Funches.
- You may know it as Burma,
but it's always gonna be
Myan-marshmellow to me.
- Points (laughs)
Ron Funches.
- Orange County.
- [Host] Points. (laughs), yup.
Jon Daly.
- Chile, chile, chile.
- Points.
Nikki.
- Viet-Nom-Nom-Nom-Nom-Nom-Nom-Nom.
- [Host] Yes, points.
Yes, Thomas.
- Tree Grows in Brooklyn But
We'll Shoot it in Vancouver.
- Yes, points.
Paul F.
- The Cash Grab Filler Series,
Volumes one through 12,
formally known as The Hobbit.
- Points.
- Woah!
- [Host] Paget.
- The Sun Also Pull Risers.
- Points.
(audience laughter)
Very current.
I'm mad about that.
- Points.
- [Host] Paul F.
- Anne of Green Gables, with
a few pages of tits thrown in.
- Yeah, points.
Tom.
- East of Edendale, But
Before You Get to the Costco.
- Okay, points.
- Oh, that's--
- Wow I got good groans,
Paget groaned at me.
- You're eating up time!
- No!
- [Host] Paul F.
- Dianetics.
(audience laughter)
- [Host] Yes, Paul Scheer.
- Pun-ger Games, starring
Pun-iffer Lawrence as Kat-pun-niss
Ever-pun (laughs).
- Alright.
That was a little pun clunky
but I'll give you punts.
Brett Gelman.
- Steven Seagal's Pun-der Siege Two.
- Punt!
Paul Scheer.
- Punisher, the movie
starring Dolph Pun-gren.
- Punts!
Andy Daly.
- Pun in the Pun.
Fun in the Sun.
- Punts.
Andy Daly.
- Two thousand pounds
equals one metric pun.
(audience applause and laughter)
- [Host] Punts.
- Brett Gelman.
- Pun-breakable, starring
Spamuel L. Crapson.
- [Host] Sarah Silverman!
- Oh!
Summa Come Laude and Incredibly Close.
- Yeah, points, points.
Scott Aukerman.
- Book Story.
- [Host] Yes.
- Like, like Toy Story.
- But with books.
Points, yeah Sarah.
- Marley and I.
- Oh!
Points.
Steve Agee.
- Young Frank-Einstein.
- Nice, points.
Steve.
- 24 Minus 12 Years a Slave.
- Right (laughs).
Points.
I don't know if 24 minus
12 is really that smart.
Scott.
- Saving Private Ryan 15% on
Car Insurance by Switching to
Geico.
- (laughs) Points.
Fantastic!
Sarah Silverman.
- Scientific Explanation on 34th Street.
- Yes, points (laughs).
Steve Agee.
- Earnest Goes to Harvard.
- (laughs) Oh my God, I
wish that had gotten made!